forgive my naivete but why his name
talent not want to do horror is the
budget too low or is there a stigma
attached I think it's I think named
talent is probably more averse to horror
because of a stigma I don't think it has
to do because I mean some horror
pictures have decent budgets and I mean
you you you could be going after I'd be
going after maybe the same names I'd be
going after if it was a romance or
comedy on that same budget level so I
don't think it's the money I I do think
it's more the stigma I had several my
horror picture had several casting
directors pass we had trouble finding a
cat we were willing to pay them you know
decent you know a decent salary and a
lot of them just didn't want to take it
and I think because they felt like it
was gonna be tough to get even even a
moderate modest names on board you know
a horror movie that was you know it's
not it's not like seven where it's like
this cuz smart thriller with some kind
of really pseudo Horus elements it's
like straight horror it's a tough sell
and I think a lot of you know a lot of
actors don't feel like maybe if they're
already established that they need to do
that genre that it's gonna help elevate
their career they want to do more
serious work or you know whatever
whatever that might be
I'm not saying I agree with that I think
our picture the basement I thought had a
really unique interesting storyline very
that's great kind of psychological or
had some gruesome moments but I think
those gruesome moments were enough to
like sort of scare people away so I
think that's stigma you know could be
the managers tell them look you don't
want to do horror because maybe even if
it's not the stickers the stigma is our
real perception is reality so if it's
perceived enough to be there then
they're just like better steer clear
you're getting offers on these other you
know dramas romantic comedies action
pictures do those because there is no
stigma with those who go ahead they're
safe that's my you know assessment I
don't know if that's a hard snacker but
from what I've seen that's definitely
actors avoiding horror pictures you know
outside a big studio ones are is
definitely real because I've experienced
it firsthand but that would be my
assessment on why
you